there are a lot of clever moments and
uncomfortable subtext than the original
Back to the Future that flew right over
your head if you watched it when you
were a kid from rock-and-roll nods the
Freudian subplots here are things that
only adults notice and back to the
future as strange as it might be for a
cool rock and roll skateboard team to
form a lasting friendship with a
middle-aged science weirdo the emotional
core back to the future is definitely
Marty McFly's relationship with Doc
Brown but believe it or not the
relationship that likely inspired Marty
and Doc's friendship is even weirder
Marty's out of his depth impulsiveness
and Doc's blunt knowledge bear a
striking resemblance to mr. Peabody and
Sherman the stars of a segment from the
Rocky and Bullwinkle show about a genius
talking dog and his young friend
traveling through time well actually
it's a time machine if that connection
seems like a stretch consider that when
Marty travels back to 1955 the first
thing he does is crash into a farm house
owned by the Peabody family and while
he's not named in the film the credits
identified the boy who assumes he's an
alien as Sherman it's a fun reference
but maybe it's also the reason why the
actual first time traveler in the film
is Einstein Doc Brown's faithful dog one
of the most appealing parts of the movie
especially for children is Marty getting
to meet his parents when they were his
age instead of inscrutable authority
figures Marty's parents in 1955 are is
awkward goofy peers seeing them at that
age isn't just weird for Marty it
reminds the younger audience that their
parents were young once two less
wholesome especially two adults are the
extremely uncomfortable scenes in which
Marty's mother tries to seduce him the
incestuous subtext that Marty having to
fend off his mother's advances and the
fact that her crush on him is enough to
threaten the entire timeline could keep
Sigmund Freud busy for years like in
kissing back to future is great for a
lot of reasons but the climactic musical
performance that Marty puts on at the
prom is a highlight and a movie full of
them it brings character beats and
offhand lines full circle as Marty
finally gets to play on stage in front
of his whole high school although about
30 years earlier than he hoped while
assuring that his parents get together
and that he gets to keep existing it's a
great scene pack
full of great references most fans got
the joke that Chuck Berry's cousin calls
him to let him know about Johnny be good
but Marty also emulates Eddie Van Halen
Jimi Hendrix and Angus Young from ac/dc
touch is added by Michael J Fox that
said as a grown-up you might think it's
a little weird for this movie to suggest
that rock-and-roll was actually invented
by a white suburban teen and then copied
by black artists in the 50s that's
pretty weird right Marty really gets put
through the wringer trying to get his
parents to hook up after he accidentally
interrupts their meet-cute in 1955 one
of the most inventive trixie polls is to
pretend to be an alien and threaten
George with death if he doesn't ask
Laraine out since Marty knows that
George is a bit of a science fiction
geek he announces his fake alien persona
was some pretty familiar names an
extraterrestrial from the planet bumpkin
by the end of the movie George has even
written a novel that based on the cover
design is at least partly inspired by
the meeting it's a cute gang but in the
world of Back to the Future
did George start writing about Darth
Vader and Vulcan in the 50s years before
Star Wars and Star Trek were released
does the McFly family's new prosperity
come from a lawsuit against George Lucas
claiming copyright infringement from
George's work and if not what did he
think when two of the most popular
sci-fi stories started referencing his
own alien encounter it's pretty easy to
imagine adult George McFly attending
sci-fi conventions trying to snag a few
precious seconds with Lucas and Gene
Roddenberry to confirm they were visited
by the strange alien 2 while it seems
like a happy ending the final moments a
back to the future are much darker than
his apparent at first glance Marty's got
in the truck of his dreams his brother
is wearing a suit to work instead of
slacking off at home and his mom and dad
seem a whole lot happier and much more
well off the thing is Marty comes from
the timeline that we see back at the
beginning of the film and he has strong
memories of what his family used to be
like before he started messing around
with the space-time continuum if you
think about it for a moment it becomes
existentially horrifying when you
remember that Marty doesn't really know
these people they look like his family
and act like an improved version of his
family but they reference moments that
never had
into this Marty leaving him confused
when he compares them to the people he
left just yesterday in 1985 imagine
having an entire life that's similar but
decidedly different from the one you
remember imagine sitting down with your
family as they make references to events
from your childhood that are just close
enough to leave you with deja vu but not
enough to spur any actual memories of
the event in question
Marty's old family with all their
problems and personality flaws are
pretty much dead replaced by strangers
who have had entire lives that he can't
remember
it's amazing that Back to the Future 2
didn't take place entirely in a
therapist office
[Music]